so this video is on magnesium and why
you're gonna feel a lot better if you
get enough from your diet and if you go
to the doctor and you get a blood test
and your magnesium deficient it's not
going to show up because 99% of that
magnesium is inside the cell not outside
the cell in your blood so just because
it comes out normal doesn't mean you're
not deficient there's something called a
subclinical deficiency where you might
be getting enough to run the basic
machinery of the body but you're not
getting the full amount to run all of
the functions and as far as magnesium
there are over 300 enzymes involved in
many different biochemical reactions
that require magnesium so out of all the
minerals magnesium is the second most
important to potassium why well simply
because you need a lot of potassium
ideally you you need 300 to 400
milligrams now
potassium you need like 4700 milligrams
that's 4700 milligrams every single day
so obviously with magnesium you need
much less but if we compare these
minerals to all the other ones you need
both of these in pretty large quantities
90% of all the magnesium is located in
the muscle in the bone and I did mention
this before but 99% of all this
magnesium is inside the cell not outside
the cell so if you're deficient you may
have bone problems like osteopenia
eventually osteoporosis you can have a
lot of muscle cramps weak muscles and
also realize that certain parts of the
vascular system have a type of muscle as
well so if you're losing magnesium your
muscles can get stiff and you're gonna
get high blood pressure from that
another really key function of magnesium
is maintaining electrical charge in your
cells
so without magnesium the electrical
system shuts down and you just don't
have enough energy to run the muscles or
the nervous system so magnesium is
really important in keeping sodium
outside the cell
keeping sodium low inside the cell and
keeping calcium low inside the cell and
keeping potassium high inside the cell
so we have these diff
Minerals kept apart by this membrane and
they all work together to form this
battery so potassium is involved in this
battery also generating energy in the
body through it's called ATP it's
involved in making DNA and proteins and
overall cell integrity so you can
imagine if you don't have enough
magnesium you're just not going to feel
quite right another symptom of a
magnesium deficiency which is
subclinical which means it's not going
to show up on a test is vascular
calcification so calcium and magnesium
work together so it's not just about
taking too much calcium it could be a
deficiency of magnesium it could also be
a deficiency in vitamin k2 and the two
main ways that you're deficient in
magnesium are number one consuming too
many refined foods okay I find
carbohydrates like the bread pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes muffins juice sugar as well as
just not consuming enough magnesium rich
foods as in leafy greens okay I mean the
average person will consume about I
think it's at 1.5 cups of vegetables per
day that's pathetic you need at least
seven hopefully 10 cups per day in the
hunter/gatherer time Paleolithic time
they estimated that an average human
consumed 600 milligrams of magnesium per
day versus the average person consumes
only 200 to 260 milligrams on average
okay the RDAs being 300 to 420 which are
not even close to this so we are really
really deficient in magnesium if you
don't feel quite right you don't have
enough energy just increase the amount
of magnesium in your diet for one week
and prove it to yourself and it did
create several other videos of magnesium
that you can check out on this page